[Música]
bienvenidos Soy Pedro Nelson Ruiz por
Natalia Cabrera esto es aquí América y
Estos son nuestros temas para hoy
llegó a su fin el tan polémico título 42
en Estados Unidos que es lo que pueden
esperar ahora los migrantes que quieran
entrar a territorio estadounidense se lo
explicamos en minutos
Guillermo lasso contra las cuerdas el
presidente de Ecuador enfrentará ante la
asamblea nacional un juicio político en
su contra por el presunto delito de
peculado analizamos en esta emisión
y en Chile la derecha radical obtuvo una
victoria en el nuevo proceso
Constituyente en un duro revés para el
gobierno de Gabriel Boris el partido
republicano obtuvo 23 asientos en el
consejo encargado de redactar un nuevo
borrador de la Carta Magna
iniciamos en Estados Unidos a las 11:59
de la noche del 11 de mayo expiró el
título 42 la medida sanitaria que
permitió por cerca de tres años bloquear
el acceso a territorio estadounidense de
millones de migrantes indocumentados
tras el fin de la medida crece la
incertidumbre de miles de personas que
esperan en la frontera Sur para entrar
al país sobre todo luego de que el
gobierno de Joe biden reiterara que
seguirá expulsando a las personas que no
cumplan con las condiciones legales para
permanecer en Estados Unidos Cómo han
recibido los migrantes el fin del título
42 en la zona fronteriza nos lo cuentan
nuestros enviados especiales a Ciudad
Juárez Aurora wyot y Andrés Suárez
el título 8 entró en vigor y plantea
graves consecuencias para todos aquellos
migrantes que quieran cruzar la frontera
sur de los Estados Unidos de forma
irregular para hacerlo de manera regular
habría que dirigirse a las oficinas de
aduana en los puentes internacionales
cosa distinta a venir hasta aquí al muro
metálico en inmediaciones de Ciudad
Juárez donde a todas luces el cruce es
ilegal y representaría para los
migrantes que quieran cruzarlo el riesgo
de que su entrada a los Estados Unidos
sea vetada por al menos cinco años
donde donde nosotros nos salgamos
puede pasar pero nosotros no nos hemos
salido desde que está desde el artículo
42 desde que llegamos nosotros peleamos
porque nosotros no hemos salido porque
nosotros llegamos fue con el otro
artículo no con esto porque ellos
quieren que nosotros nos salgamos para
que cuando volvamos a ir a otro lado ya
nos vaya a regir ese artículo cuando uno
de nosotros le pregunta que Entonces
nosotros qué derecho tenemos Ya estando
desde allá afuera y ellos nos dicen que
por ser migrantes nosotros no tenemos
derechos claritico nos dijo y nos lo
dijo en español este es uno de los
momentos clave las últimas personas que
se encuentran frente a la puerta 42
están entregando a las autoridades
cuando antes en el día en que se estaba
acabando el título 42 había un millar de
personas ellos Ahora son los últimos en
el día en que ya está imperando el
título ocho sin embargo les han dicho
que es muy probable que corran el riesgo
de que los sometan bajo esta nueva
política fronteriza no conocemos eso
supuestamente hemos visto que el 42 era
que te podían deportar
y el 8 expulsar hasta ahí se nos hace
más aunque son pocos no todos los
migrantes que están llegando a la
frontera conocen del título ocho una
política que no consiste simplemente en
entregarse voluntariamente a las
autoridades sino demostrarle a un juez
que los motivos de su migración van más
allá de no tener una oportunidad laboral
Y tiene más relación con una persecución
política Luego si estas personas son
expulsadas y reinciden durante su
penalidad de cinco años de ser
capturadas podrían ir a prisión 18 meses
y ser vetados hasta 10 años pero muchos
corren el riesgo solamente por
encontrarse con sus familias
pasamos ahora a Ecuador el presidente
Guillermo lasso enfrentará ante la
asamblea nacional un juicio político en
su contra esto después de que el
legislativo aprobara continuar con el
proceso el jefe de estado es acusado por
el delito de peculado en el marco de un
contrato para el transporte de petróleo
que se firmó antes de su mandato Pero
que según la oposición el presidente
negó a darlo por terminado pese a varias
denuncias de irregularidades para
separar al lazo del poder se
necesitarían 92 votos para analizar el
contexto político que atraviesa Ecuador
saludamos en Quito a Fernando Carrión él
es analista político y académico de
flacsoe Ecuador Fernando Gracias por
estar en aquí América la gran pregunta
que quizás estén haciendo en Ecuador Es
que tan factible es que lazo termine
siendo separado del poder la oposición
tiene los votos suficientes para
destituirlo
tuvimos el día martes la convocatoria al
proceso este de juzgamiento del
presidente de la república y En esa
ocasión se aprobó esta decisión con 88
votos hubo muchas muchos asambleístas
que no asistieron y el resto o votaron
en contra o se abstuvieron para que el
presidente de la república tenga que
salir se necesitan 92 votos es las es
decir estarían faltando cuatro más pero
aquí las fuerzas están moviendo de un
lado y del otro en unos casos sube en
otros casos baja eso va a haber
incertidumbre hasta el día de la
votación pese a no estar de acuerdo con
el proceso el presidente aseguró que
asistirá al pleno de la asamblea para
defenderse de estas acusaciones sin
embargo aún tendría otras vías para
evitar el juicio político entre ellas
está la llamada muerte Cruzada esa
herramienta constitucional Aún es viable
y cómo afectaría a la ya frágil
estabilidad política del Ecuador
bueno haya una medida previa que ya
acaba de hacer uso el presidente de la
república que es una solicitud a la
corte constitucional para que vea si
efectivamente el proceso que se está
llegando a cabo está dentro del marco
jurídico porque lo que ocurrió el día
del martes pasado cuando se convocó al
juicio político es que el en la asamblea
debía haberse pronunciado sobre el
informe de la comisión de fiscalización
y el informe de la comisión de de
fiscalización no se aprobó con mayoría
sino con minorías es decir no se aprobó
Pero qué es lo que aconteció el
presidente de la asamblea convocó a esa
reunión y ahí se presentó simplemente
una una posición de uno de los
interpelantes y frente a eso se tomó
esta votación de los ochenta y ocho
votos de tal manera que podría incluso
antes de eso Si es que la corte
constitucional se pronuncia en términos
de que eso no es jurídico pues el juicio
en caso de que siga efectivamente el
presidente tiene la otra opción que es
la muerte Cruzada la muerte Cruzada No
es otra cosa más que una decisión que
puede tomar el presidente de la
república de cerrar la asamblea y
convocar inmediatamente a elecciones ese
es un proceso que sin duda tomará
demorará no menos de seis siete meses y
la persona que salga electa
probablemente bueno no sea el presidente
de la república y tendrá hasta la
finalización del período de el
presidente lasso para culminar sus
funciones Esto es algo así como un año y
medio
es Fernando Carrión analista político y
académico de flaxo Ecuador gracias por
su tiempo para Frank 24 nosotros
continuamos y cambiamos de información
Vamos hasta chile las elecciones para
elegir nuevo consejo Constituyente que
deberá redactar una nueva constitución
resultaron en un revés para el gobierno
de Gabriel borich los ultraderechistas
liderados por José Antonio kast fueron
los más votados Ramiro cué Barberena nos
cuenta más
una propuesta impulsada por la izquierda
pero que deja a la derecha en una
posición favorable los resultados de las
elecciones celebradas en Chile el
domingo marcaron la superioridad de los
conservadores un escenario opuesto al de
los comicios anteriores el partido
republicano se quedó con 23 de los 50
escaños disponibles siete más que la
facción oficialista unidad para Chile Si
se juntan con la derecha de chile seguro
podrían decir la confección de la
Constitución sin pactar con los
izquierdistas el presidente Gabriel
borich felicitó a los ganadores pero les
pidió mesura En nombre del estado
y les invito
templanza el proceso anterior
y debemos decirlo
fracasó entre otras cosas porque no
supimos escucharnos entre quienes
pensábamos distinto Franz 24 diálogo con
Néstor Aburto director de contenidos de
radio bío-bío que me explicó el panorama
que enfrentará el país trasandino se va
a alinear esta derecha en el consejo
constitucional que parte el próximo seis
de junio con la derecha tradicional es
una de las grandes dudas porque
eventualmente podría existir una
posibilidad de que la derecha
tradicional pudiera pactar con algunos
sectores de la centro izquierda que son
pocos pero que podrían pactar y hacer un
solo bloque eso es lo que está en juego
a contar de las próximas semanas los 50
miembros del Consejo Constituyente
confeccionarán una nueva propuesta de
Constitución para el domingo 17 de
diciembre fecha en la que se votará un
plebiscito de salida donde la ciudadanía
decidirá se aprueba o rechaza el cambio
en la Guatemala rural donde la mayor
parte de la población es de origen Maya
los índices de malnutrición infantil
alcanzan cifras récord la pobreza y la
falta de acceso a la educación son Causa
y efecto de los problemas nutricionales
nuestra corresponsal para Centroamérica
Aurora wayud se acercó a estas
comunidades para constatar la espiral
que limita el desarrollo de la población
guatemalteca bueno va a cumplir dos años
y la delgadez de sus brazos revela un
preocupante estado de salud en el amario
digamos que está en riesgo el niño
Guatemala es el país con la tasa de
desnutrición Crónica infantil más alta
de latinoamérica según acción contra el
hambre y aquí en el departamento de
Huehuetenango es donde se encuentra la
mayor cantidad de niños con hambre la
inseguridad alimentaria en esas tierras
áridas se agudizó por el cambio
climático dejando desemparadas a varias
familias
ya no hay nada que hacer con él
no sé qué va a ser de mi hijo
siempre ha estado
mucho tristeza por mi bebé para comer
cuando uno se salda con muerte es la
desnutrición acarrea otras secuelas con
el estómago vacío los estudiantes no
tienen el desarrollo cognitivo
suficiente para facilitar el aprendizaje
cuando yo hago lectura con ellos apenas
me leen palabras por la falta de
alimentación en sus hogares aquí cuando
empezamos el ciclo escolar pues muchos
niños se inscriben ya tarde por lo mismo
que los padres de familia lo llevan a
trabajar en las fincas para para tener
de Qué comer
para salir de esa espiral la fundación
football de Henry le apuesta a la
educación nutricional de las madres
que mejor verdad que de su huerto para
su cocina tener un huerto fecundo y
saber aprovecharlo puede marcar la
diferencia para los niños de la
comunidad vemos verdad familias que los
dos jefes del hogar Este son de
escolaridad muy baja Entonces eso es lo
que les limita a conseguir un buen
trabajo afecta a los niños porque no se
les da la alimentación que ellos
requieren según las Naciones Unidas al
ritmo actual Guatemala necesitaría 100
años para erradicar la desnutrición
Crónica infantil
y la cifra de la semana nos llega desde
el Salvador y es que según el gobierno
de nayib bukele el pasado 10 de mayo se
registraron 0 homicidios en todo el país
siendo el día número 365 sin homicidios
desde que llegó bukele al poder en junio
de 2019 Sin embargo hay que aclarar que
esta cifra no puede ser corroborada
independientemente Gracias por
acompañarnos en esta emisión de aquí
América pueden enviarnos sus comentarios
en redes sociales a la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas en la producción estuvo
Jennifer Guevara pueden ver esta emisión
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
France 24.com
[Música]